we came in Orlando I William how are you
good afternoon and nice to speak with
you you too how can we help well I've
got a 20 year old daughter has recently
moved out of state with a friend staying
with family and she's talking about
establishing credit and going to school
and I vaguely heard to mention that
student loan they're both pretty much
blank slates this time I like to start
them off in the right direction with
information are you paying for any of
this well they mentioned something about
are you paying for her to go to school
are you supporting her in any way she
has a 539 plan that you own are the you
control yes 529 plan okay all right I
got to be nice so your question is what
then how does she need to the best way
for her to establish credit okay that
you really need it and should they take
out a student loan well we can answer
those questions number one no she does
not need to take out a student loan
there are ways to go to school debt-free
the fact that she's out of state may
harm her and that she may have to take
out of state tuition depending on how
long she's been living at her current
residence that's going to depend on her
tuition but the credits yeah I get this
all the time especially from young
adults this idea of establishing your
credit because you hear everyone in your
lives tell you that you need to build up
a credit score and when you look at a
credit score how it's calculated the
only way to have a credit score is to be
in debt and staying in debt and the
reason the main reason to have a credit
score is to go into more debt and so if
she is you know under if she's trying to
live a life debt-free than know she will
not have a credit score but you can
still survive life without a credit
score because again the only reason you
really need one is to go into debt and
some people you know so you need when to
rent an apartment and insurance and cell
phone all those things and I've done all
of those things without a credit score
mine is undetermined because I've never
borrowed money and so again you can get
what you can get through all those
obstacles it takes a little bit more
hard work but it's doable and it's worth
it versus going in debt so just to bump
up a credit score
that information I heard you talking
about smart money smart kids we've got
information in that book yes yes let me
send you a copy and it will help you
with your twenty-year-old discussion the
thing you've got to do is having had
some 20 year olds that are all in the
20-somethings now and grown and on their
own but the way with the tact that
Sharon my wife and I used when we were
dealing with these kind of discussions
with the kids obviously we had discussed
this particular subject long before but
any discussion we were having with the
kids it was based on two things number
one I'm first going to try to persuade
you to do what is wise because I love
you and I'm going to use the tack that I
would use with a friend of mine over
coffee and I'm going to say this is why
building a credit score is a dumb idea
this is why going into student loan debt
is a dumb idea this is why you need to
be on a written budget we have the money
in the 529 for you to go to school and
and I'm going to attempt to do that
first but ultimately if someone's going
to engage that I love one of my children
is well at that at that age was going to
engage in a behavior that was going to
bring harm to them that I considered
stupid and against my value system I'm
not above saying I'm not going to
support you financially so you got no
access to this money if you're going to
do that if you're going to go in ways
that I don't agree with I'm giving you
no money and and I'm not above doing
that at all
so that's something to think about
that's but that's kind of your worst
case scenario scenario if your
persuasion methodology fails how much is
in the 529 maybe 15,000 okay and what is
her tuition well she hasn't started yet
I said out-of-state tuition is is real
expensive maybe twice as much as why is
she there why isn't she at home if she
wants to go to school well family split
planning your mom is there yes yeah and
she can she not establish residence
through that I would think that her
mom's only been there for maybe five
months okay that's a problem all right
well first thing I would do is get with
the local in-state school and see what
the guidelines are
solving that given that the family has
permanently transferred and set up
residency there and they didn't do so
for purposes of getting in-state tuition
but how can I get around this and
qualify for in-state and I'm going to
really push on that and fight on that
because it's not like that she did this
just to get the deal right I mean you
know so a lot of schools and a lot of
states have reasonable exceptions in
these situations and so I'm really going
to push through that I'm going to apply
for a bunch of scholarships I'm going to
be working wor K is a good thing and
that's how we're going to handle it
around our house and so yeah but if
she's going to force her way into
student loans she she can work and get
scholarships a fifteen thousand dollar
head start and get her way through if we
can get the out-of-state tuition waived
and I'm going to go in there and fight
scratch and claw with administrators sit
in front of them have meetings I'm not
going to just accept the statement on
their website as to what goes on I'm
going to push this envelope on this